[Applause]
oh wow uh
first of all big game James I appreciate
all the kind words uh you know what you
you know have done for this franchise as
well uh doesn't go unnoticed you're one
of the greatest Lakers of all time one
of the greatest players of all time and
I appreciate those words
uh
you know on behalf of myself but this is
literally about
this crew right here this is my starting
five right here you know my two boys
Ronnie Bryce my daughter Zuri my mom
Gloria my wife Savannah like this is my
starting five and I wouldn't be able to
do the things that I do on a day-to-day
basis I wouldn't be out I wouldn't be
able to come on this court and showcase
my talent to you guys every single night
if I didn't have the support and I
didn't have the commitment from my
family that allowed me to do the things
that I do so you know I wouldn't be
standing up here I wouldn't be who I am
I wouldn't be able to inspire so many
people all over the world I wouldn't be
able to inspire the Laker faithful I
wouldn't be able to inspire nobody if I
didn't have
the sacrifices and the commitment for my
starting five right here so please give
them a round of applause please
um I just think back to my journey
um you know you know being a kid from
Akron Ohio and you know when I was three
years old on December 25th
1988 my mother brought me a Little Tikes
hoop and there's actually a photo uh
floating around of that Christmas gift
um
that moment I fell in love with
basketball
I was about to turn four years old on
December December 30th for that year
but from that moment on I knew that that
orange
sphere uh was something that I always
wanted to be a part of my journey in
who wouldn't know someone said on social
media that that was the
biggest investment
the in the history of of mankind a 20
Little Tikes hoop could turn into what
it's turned to today
um Mom thank you thank you so much
um just you know growing up in a small
town of Akron Ohio
um as a underprivileged
single parent household only only child
you feel that you're never going to make
it out you feel like
um the statistics are built up against
you you feel like the system is built
against you to not succeed you feel like
there's no way that you're ever gonna
have an opportunity for your dreams to
become a reality
and um I didn't I didn't allow those
moments
to uh deter me from my from my dreams I
had dreams every day of playing in the
NBA I had dreams every day of being an
inspiration to so many people
um you know I had dreams of being able
one day to be able to throw no look
passes like Magic Johnson
um to be able to to be able to shoot
fade aways like Michael Jordan to be
able to you know have a crossover like
Allen Iverson to be able to have a afro
and jumper you know in a dunk contest
like Kobe Bryant
you know I looked up to so many athletes
and so many people along my journey and
they gave me the inspiration and they
allowed my dreams to not die
um and as I got older and older and
older as I went through the high school
ranks and I got drafted and I always
felt it was my job and my responsibility
to come out and play the game at a high
level and be as great as I can be
because there is a kid in the inner city
somewhere that's looking for inspiration
and that's going to need it and maybe
get it from me so
hahaha
so as I sit up here and I know we have a
game to be played um as I sit up here
and look across these uh these jumbo uh
this Jumbotron and this thing going
across the around the crypto right now
and seeing the NBA all-time leading
scorer is just so it's so surreal to me
but the one thing I know uh for sure is
I've never cheated the game of
basketball and I would never cheat the
game of basketball because it's given so
much to myself it's given so much to my
family my beautiful wife has been
I mean she's the real MVP if you want to
be completely honest she's actually the
all-time leading scorer if you want to
be completely honest
my boys will say uh they they are the
all-time leading scorers but I don't
think that my I don't think Savannah
will allow that tonight but uh uh but my
family is is everything to me and uh
um you guys over the last five years
have become family to me as well so
thank you to the Laker faithful
you guys are unbelievable and um you
know every night I step on the floor I
understand and I truly have a huge
responsibility and understand what it
means to represent the Los Angeles
Lakers when I step on this floor so
thank you thank you so much